like such a nice smell to them and I
don't know maybe it does have to do with
if you're not fapping you just have more
like pheromones you can just like I
probably smell like
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
but they're really making advances in
t-shirt technology where it can like
it's tighten the shoulders there's like
there's like Instagram ads for like
these specific t-shirts all the time
that are supposed to fit like the
regular guy's body yeah yes exactly this
is nice though I feel pretty pretty
powerful I say we we're discounts we'll
start with the T-shirt talk yeah welcome
to cats after dark this is what you
changed so hell you look different it's
a little different uh yeah I got blacker
yeah
is that too much I'm mad at him actually
I know I I I I people know I texted him
we were gonna do it on Monday we're
switching to days because now a
Chappelle is no longer on fighter a kid
and you made your announcement which we
haven't talked about on this yeah I left
fighter and the kid I think it was just
time for me to graduate honestly it felt
like that was my like I was talking to
George about this he says that he feels
as though being a thick boy is his
podcast University experience I feel
like I just graduated from my University
experience yeah now you're creating your
own content making six figures a month
she needs more subscribers by the way so
subscribe hi uh but yeah Chappelle could
not make it today which is why we have
Nick in the chair damn right I uh I'm
gonna Wally pip him
uh Wally pip uh he was an outfielder for
the Yankees and
ah he got hurt and then I think it was
either Mickey Mantle or Joe DiMaggio
like stepped in for him and then the guy
never got his job back oh God and Wally
pip was actually really really good so a
hostile takeover yeah essentially got it
except if he wants to come back next
week he can have the seat back because I
I want him here I like chilling just
picking the spots
sniping welcome back Kyle thank you
all of the short Kings here and we just
wanted to ask you some questions about
how you felt with the diss track on you
guys I'll let Christian take that first
Delia can eat my dick that's what I
think
[Music]
it's a little harsh he didn't make a
track to making fun of you did he he
said the Asian something he wasn't he
just says you like fishing that's all
yeah you're Asian he made systems he
made fun of the entire show okay yeah so
really we should just roast him all
together I think we should all just beat
the [ __ ] out of him
um you know it kind of hurt but um I
think it's bringing awareness to short
people everywhere so whether you like
this song or hate it um you know people
are Gonna Know About Us yeah let's let's
hear it let's hear it
um also today uh we're gonna talk about
I wanted to address the controversy in
the podcast world right now I mean we
got to everybody's asking us about it
everybody's hitting it up and I'm
personally I'm out on Marty mush I just
can I cannot believe he would date Ria
right guys team hashtag team think about
that but I actually don't know too much
about that like bar stool world
like there's a love triangle happening
currently
why why are you team Hank uh he ever
this is bar stool weird inner office
drama that they're really playing up for
content right now but Hank is the
producer for pardon my take one of the
biggest podcasts in the world uh with
big cat and uh PFT and so he's been he's
OG Barstool he's now head of content
there he's like making bank has shares
in the company once they finally like
completely sell it it's a big deal
everybody loves him everybody loves tank
then there's this other guy Marty Moshe
got hired a couple years ago and no one
really knows what he does and his whole
character is he kind of plays this dumb
guy and then there's this chick uh Maria
kufo or something they're for part of a
podcast called chicks in the office that
got pretty popular
Maria dated Hank I sound insane
recapping this but uh Maria did hang for
four years she broke up because she's
like oh I never lived a single life
she's only like 23 24. that's fair and
then it just came out that she for a
while had been secretly dating this
Marty mush guy and that guy Marty mush
has ruined his career because everybody
likes Hank Moore and him and they've
basically admitted that they're not
going to renew his contract really I
mean like big cat is like the number two
guy the company Dave portnoy's number
one and they both they're like [ __ ] that
guy that's a scumbag move we'll see what
happens but we're not going to do
content with him and if those two guys
aren't doing content with you at
Barstool it's so she cheated on him she
didn't cheat actually they broke up
yeah he's like hey I don't want to be in
a relationship right now and then later
is like in a relationship with someone
else with Marty mush yeah yeah and now
it makes it seem like it's not that she
didn't want to be in a relationship is
that she didn't want to be in a
relationship with him but that's not
what she said yeah yeah so I think
that's the cats after dark official
stance where team Hank right right guys
yeah yeah absolutely
whatever Nick says so no more asking us
about the controversy
oh and also unrelated next week we're
gonna have George kimmelon maybe uh he's
looking at schedule but uh tiger belly
producer and and probably diving into
controversy more I'll ask we'll ask him
about Marty mush do you think Marty if
you had to take a while he's a smart guy
he's got to be team Hank yeah hit it
Christian
documents
[Music]
because I complimented
[Music]
guys
[Music]
[Music]
not really give a [ __ ] about that I'm
glad he does
oh God
yeah you're sick
[Music]
that's fire can we just go ahead and go
out on the limb and say this is the
podcast version of Hit Em Up it really
is I wish that's what that is we need
someone who can respond [ __ ] you want to
do like in a country Diddy and fire back
you have to do uh a track with brows oh
nice rebuttal that's in the works yeah
also we should probably change the sign
oh [ __ ] you're right uh let's fix that
there we go there that's much better
good call Christian thank you
we'll try to do it before the episode's
going forward although that was a cool
effect yeah it was great all right let's
switch it back no I'm just kidding
uh what were we talking oh you're
leaving what are you gonna do cat you
quit too um we're dropping like flies I
don't really know what I'm gonna do I
know I'm gonna keep doing only fans
gonna keep doing the show
um and I
don't have a plan so I'm gonna figure it
out you should travel blog yeah because
then like you only like even if you just
like break even on it you just get to
see the world for free and do some Vlogs
like you already have your income like I
feel like that's what people do when
they have a following just to have like
a lifestyle business and you can just
knows how to Vlog too yeah it's a good
camera I don't know if I am great at
that though you could pay an editor yeah
at this point true I I feel very you
know
everyone's learning I don't know how to
Vlog in public it makes me so shy and so
awkward and I get mad at Stevie when he
tries to do right by me by encouraging
me to do it because now I feel like he's
telling me what to do so I snap on him a
lot I was in the Bay Area for Mother's
Day weekend and I was planning on
vlogging the trip and I started
recording and there are just certain
parts where I didn't feel like taking my
camera out and recording wherever we
were at at that particular moment and
Stevie would remind me like oh like
bring your camera out you should Vlog
this you should record this blah blah
and I have such a trigger with people
telling me what to do especially like
people in my personal life if it's work
I really don't care personal life the
moment he said you should like I see red
I'm like shut up no I'm not doing that
see if that would have been camera that
would have been an awesome Vlog yeah you
could be like one of those relationships
couples yeah but I think it's gonna I'm
gonna look so terrible if I do that
because the only reason why I yell at
him is because he would rather have me
yell at him than not say anything my
default is I don't want to say anything
I'm going to stay quiet I just need my
space like leave me alone for five
minutes while I cool off he cannot deal
with that he gets angry if I don't talk
to him because you feel like he feels
like it's me abandoning him like I'm
pulling out of the relationship so he'd
rather have me yell at him and cuss at
him and he'll take it with a smile he's
like this is so much better I'm having
like say anything that's like the exact
same situation with Jules like we ever
get in a fight she like shuts down she
won't talk I'm
I think it's an Asian thing we're not or
at least for me I was raised where I
wasn't necessarily allowed to show any
negative emotions so now as an adult I
don't really know how to express
anything negative in a
healthy way where I don't then feel
guilty afterwards or I feel like I did
something wrong yeah and it's so funny
because like it's just like
the more the more she's quiet the more I
like so we just like get further yeah
further and further apart it's crazy do
you have a solution for it any tips for
me uh I just need to chill out
I I get I get better I get better but um
abrupt transition but the the last time
this happened was right after we
finished watching uh uh everything
everywhere all at once anybody I have
not watched that yet I heard it's so
good it's incredible it's such a Trippy
movie it's really funny to no one's even
heard of it I think they're can you
bring up the I think the film has only
been released in a select amount of
theaters it's not like a nationwide film
that's having normal showings but it was
uh it was like it was like a little Kung
fui with a lot of the parts sci-fi it
was sick I actually don't even want to I
knew nothing about it going in that's
what everyone tells me that the fact
that when you watch the trailer it's
very ambiguous when you go and you don't
know what to expect and you're Blown
Away by the end of it uh I don't even is
it
what is it uh is it like a Multiverse
situation uh Yes actually the word
Multiverse is thrown around a lot well
yeah
multiverses are huge yeah with Doctor
Strange
uh what else uh that might be it spider
well I guess that's all Marvel I guess
that's all Marvel Marvel loves the
Multiverse situation
they're making a killing it's the way
they can explain away their
inconsistencies with the different
movies essentially to cop out but it
works Kevin feige was like you know what
we have been [ __ ] up I know a way to
clean all this up Multiverse bring in
Doctor Strange it is uh Doctor Strange
is that is that a show
it's a movie I think they are making it
a TV series eventually but yeah it's a
movie because I like that guy in the
Spider-Man movie he was funny but I I
haven't seen all the models in uh
Spider-Man Multiverse they had Doctor
Strange he was like the one sending him
to like different universes or whatever
oh oh that's actually his name yeah
Benedict Cumberbatch oh I found out that
his fan base is called uh they call
themselves The cumber [ __ ]
these guys and girls yeah I guess so
it's just like that's his fan base I
guess I'm a cumber [ __ ] I like that
guys yeah I like that yeah I'm so tight
his voice is so nice yeah it's so deep
uh
what else do we want to talk about well
George is here yeah oh yeah George he
talked to him he was on the road hey
guys hey and because of him and because
of thick boy like scheduling uh posting
he was already worked a full week by the
time we aired the episode that you were
driving here yep how's it going it's
going very well I've spent the week
learning Premiere and dinkering with my
footage from my trip so I'm working on
my own Vlog that's going to be on my own
channel called go George go uh selfless
plug right there oh yeah
so I invented it
yeah my
um process with making the videos
literally just me learning how to do
everything so it's not going to be you
know High the best quality but it's true
to me and it's going to be very honest
and that's really all I can do in this
world is be me that's amazing thank you
guys and the best way
the best way to learn editing I think is
actually like
have a project that you're like I'm
trying to get to the finish of this
rather than like oh I'm gonna watch
videos and learn how to do every
different thing like try to accomplish
what you're doing and then all of a
sudden you're like and because it's so
personal it's like I like there's like
one and a half second Clips in it that
I'm like nope needs to go out I like I'm
like it's taking so much of my like what
I want it to be because it's my video
that I'm like oh this is why people will
take so long to pump their content out
sometimes because they get too dedicated
to it so you just got to find out what
parts of your life is very boring and
and like people like those boring Parts
yeah it's a tricky one huh yeah it is
it's it's a balance of trying to keep
people's attention while not looking
fake to yourself and like the cat was
talking about uh we said maybe start a
vlog just talk on the camera how you
talk to yourself like do you talk to
yourself when you want we don't want
your house camera oh my God I didn't
realize not everybody talks to them so
cells because growing up my mom always
talked to herself it was always normal
to me I thought everyone kind of had a
conversation with themselves either
internally or out loud just to get their
thoughts out yeah apparently that's not
every not everyone does that yeah
apparently illness
that voice in my head mental illness yes
my mom talked to herself quite a bit as
well she's schizophrenic but
maybe she's not talking to her no she
was oh true
it's a Multiverse what have you been up
to Kyle uh you know I've been around
you know some highs some lows
um you know everyone's talking about
their relationships and you know that's
great that everyone's happy and in
relationships but not everyone is so
please stop that
um I did get a tattoo
um while I was gone
um just kind of spur the moment from Dan
Smith
um so I did that and we just been really
busy at thick boy you know uh fighting
fighting you know internet battles and
and making great content are those uh is
that the stoplight with all green lights
it is yeah it is
um green lights is one of my favorite
books but I don't want to get into the
whole meaning of it but uh yeah it's
like sewn on it looks like if you look
close you're not going to see it there
but uh it's like stitched on like uh
like a stone thing because that's
different have you ever have you ever
heard the Aloe Black song green lights I
love Aloe Black I love you can you play
that he's got a great voice I love uh
green lights yellow black
um but yeah it's like uh he just sings
about like the best day he had and he's
just driving he just hits every Green
Light I love Aloe Black oh he's great uh
I think the first time I heard him he
did the song for Brick Mansions with
Paul Walker uh it was like I'm the man
I'm the man you got her interested
yeah and it was also um yes sir yeah I
love that song it was also a Colin
Kaepernick commercial really uh
happened and Russell Wilson
oh this is a great cruising song yeah
got the top down
I'm in patreon mode we're gonna get
demonetized sorry Mike
uh but uh yeah he's great he's the man I
feel like he's like a
I don't know like a new like
Ray Charles or something like Soulful
kind of kind of dude like he's not blind
he can see but
but he's like old school old school
Vibes yeah I've never seen him like
touring though or anything I'm sure he
does but like is it is he headlining his
own stuff yet I would imagine he's
getting close that's one thing like I
always hear about artists I like after
they play I need to like look into
people's touring schedules and stuff
that's why we didn't see Olivia Rodrigo
I want to go watch her so bad I found
out her set's about 30 to 40 minutes
long because she really doesn't she only
has that one album yeah so she does a
lot of covers she does a lot of covers
while she's out too
um who did you who did you go to though
I thought you went to her I went to go
see Billy eilish Oh Billy eilish and I
cried happy tears oh my God it was
beautiful I saw Jason Momoa beautiful
man I screamed at him and said Khal
Drogo I love you and yeah it was great
it was beautiful I love her uh what
other recommendations do we have for
people I gave out everything everywhere
all at once uh what have you been
watching enjoying actually you know what
you guys mentioned tours and music oh
you know this already Nick but we have a
show May 17th on a Tuesday it's me
little brows Chappelle has been mad
peaceful everyone here is going all
right yes
yeah so if you guys can make it out that
would make they'll make our no it would
make a a huge deal for me if you guys
came out so I'll take these pictures if
you want yeah for free whatever oh no
but I'd rather use this guy just yeah
enjoy it I'm gonna dance too I'm gonna
do both yeah I'll absolutely be there so
at the Troubadour it's only 15 bucks for
the tickets uh I'm sure Nick will put a
link down below I will all right cool
that's it guys we're doing our first
concert in L.A May 17th at the
Troubadour baby gonna be doing some
original like haters will say right yeah
we can do here
I'll be there too
[Applause]
I had actually seen that like scroll
across my feed but like you just like
you watch a little you don't finish it
that was a great ending that was a great
ending you didn't finish it Nick of all
people I knew that I knew the gist I'm
gonna be there I don't have to be sold
too so join us everybody join us please
we'd love to see you meet you talk to
you
what have I watched uh The Marvelous
Miss Mabel I know I'm behind but that's
a pretty good show what is that what is
that about it's a female stand-up
comedian I'm kind of like going through
like the whole grind of becoming you
know successful in her her business
manager robbed her I'm only like three
episodes then but it is pretty funny so
um that's all I really have to offer
show wise right now I'll give it a
chance I like giving stand-up comedy
shows a chance I loved crashing didn't
love no offense Eric Griffin uh I'm
dying up here I'm dying up here it was
too like dark and like I don't know it
was less funny yeah than I wanted in a
show about stand-up comedy did anybody
watch crashing with uh Pete Holmes no
amazing I think I did I don't remember
though it's good stuff I really haven't
been watching it actually there's one
thing I've been watching like in heavy
rotation there's this professional eater
his name is Randy santel Stevie and I
will sit in front of the couch and watch
him eat like devour food for literally
hours until three in the morning I'm
excited and I
like I just I I love him so much he has
such a Charisma about him he eats like
nobody I've ever seen in my life he's a
huge man he is about I want to say six
five like all American Man Randy santel
Randy and he eats a bunch of food he
tours the country go like promoting
these little like Mom and Pop uh
restaurants that have these food
challenges and he's on YouTube yeah and
he's on YouTube that's him he's great he
actually got up he used to be like buff
was on the show uh Spartacus for a
little bit he was like a gladiator in it
and he started doing professional eating
got up to 400 pounds and then he started
documenting his weight loss journey and
he lost over 100 pounds afterwards does
he still eat yeah he still eats this is
his full-time job I love him Steve and I
are such a big such big fans we'll watch
a root for him on the catcher like Randy
Randy it's so cathartic to me you know
watch someone eat a copious amount of
food I think it's because my favorite
activity used to be binge eating and now
I don't do it anymore I like watching
other people do it that's like Memories
you know that's a a good way to call
them
Faso cut or this is just kind of he
looks pretty fast he starts real strong
up top he devours Foods very very
quickly and then he slows down over time
Wisconsin Wisconsin yes
perfect video to pick
and there's always a crowd he documents
it on his Facebook page and so people
will come by and watch Steven I actually
want to travel somewhere to watch him
eat
that could be your crap along you follow
I would follow him around the country I
love him this is what I'm talking about
like this guy has carved out a life for
himself where he goes around and eats
and he gets paid everywhere he goes you
could do that you could just be
companion content for Randy oh my God I
would love that it's like well produced
yeah I believe it's him and his
girlfriend who go around the country and
they kind of help each other record
while they're there some of these food
vloggers uh like we discuss a lot on my
other podcast another podcast show uh
but uh Badlands trucks can you can you
YouTube Badlands jugs battling chugs
yeah uh this guy is
awesome
uh oh I've seen this guy too
he's huge like uh both physically and
his YouTube channel numbers
uh so what is what does he do on his
channel he chugs sodas he really gives
you a nice like uh he describes the
notes of the sodas he's gonna be
chugging uh and really lets you into his
world and he always drinks out of Das
Boot which is another hilarious thing I
have diabetes
[Laughter]
oh he's gonna die doing what he loves
you know he has a patreon that you can
if you pay a little bit of money and
request a little something he'll follow
through like I saw a YouTube video that
someone was like can you get a milk and
say this specific line and down the milk
and he went to the gas station and
bought the little milk the Chug it for
the little patreon video well look guess
we got our next episode I will be
opening up the wall book what do we want
to see this guy eat ooh
um uh tiger thick little tiger thick
he's gotten so much better I can't
believe this is
oh I love this
because I love people doing eating
challenges I love people doing the like
mukbang stuff where they're talking
about stuff and eating like copious
amounts of food
yeah okay I think we're good I love that
but yeah I I told he talks to the camera
more about like what he's drinking and
The Taste and stuff he does one where
there's like I didn't even know they had
this many flavors to Mountain Dew but it
was like 12 different mountains like a
sommelier yeah soda yes for real I can't
remember this guy's name but he's
another food challenge guy who's like he
goes he tries like the
all the newest fast food items and he
reviews them and he's so enthusiastic I
watched another guy his name is Matt
Stoney he's a competitive I wonder where
he eats as fast as he possibly can and
his channel is amazing and as you can
see his mandibles are like he's one of
those like skinny Asian dudes who just
eat so much food and stretches out his
stomach so much and then he just stays
skinny somehow because his metabolism do
you think do you think that they Purge
afterwards maybe I heard a good amount
of people who do that for a living do
Purge afterwards just to feel better
because they feel so physically sick
afterwards great way to lose a couple
pounds before a show Zoolander when they
you can read minds believe me uh Ian k
it's not Ethan Ian k uh he peep this out
food reviews he's the man have you seen
the report of the week
uh we'll watch him too this we are now a
show that reviews food reviewers we all
love watching this stuff he brought in
these guys with hilarious we keep
watching them and then like I wanted to
like bring in one and I brought in
report of the week and he like laughed
in my face he's like everybody knows
about report of the week not because
it's bad but because like that guy's so
big everybody's aware of him
piece of a chicken along with some of
the sauce and the pickles guys and stuff
Parts what I'm expecting it to be a
little bit of buttermilk ranch goodness
along with time to heat a buffalo with
this one here let's keep going in though
but as you're gonna see very tasting
nonetheless you're loving this I love
this guy he always goes oh that's a
pretty tasty situation
yeah getting a nice tangle of Buffalo
along the creaminess of Branch with this
one guys it's not nearly as hot as I
thought it was going to be just a little
bit of a Sizzle right there it's not bad
for what you're getting here but
naturally very familiar because the
chicken is really standing out very
familiar in that flavor department for
Popeyes along with those pickles in the
bottom but so far guys I'm not bad for
this chicken sandwich okay do you think
word will get back to any of these
people that were doing a review I've
reached out to Ian k yeah I've I fear he
may have watched what we did and thought
we were making fun of them which I am
not sir send him this one yeah let them
know it's nothing but love and support I
didn't know they had a buffalo ranch
chicken uh sandwich I'm kind of excited
about it I don't like buffalo ranch but
that looks pretty damn good you don't
like Buffalo Ranch okay I don't like the
buffalo sauce that's a huge component of
the I know I know nothing but Buffalo I
could probably do because I like Ranch
but don't you guys love do the best
thing to do is if when you guys are
ordering food like for Postmates or
whatever and you watch videos of that
food before you eat it and it comes and
then you eat it it's the best feeling
like foreplay before your food yeah
what's exactly how Google like what
restaurants we're gonna go to I'll do
that first look at menu items and see
them eat it and I'm like [ __ ] we're
gonna go now it's like what he likes to
do really
edging oh my God I'm glad someone uh he
do but he
felt less fat in my life
God you like to eat yeah I like how it
was like a test to see who the edging
was in the room oh yeah I'm sure I know
what it is oh okay
he doesn't listen to the podcast thank
God but uh my tank loves doing that how
do you know because he uh
I don't know how we discovered it I
think like we're me and my brother were
busting his balls and like he just made
it that would make sense
um and then once we found out that he
was into edging we made a joke because
coincidentally the hockey team that he
played for growing up was called the
Edgewood Bandits so
he just has always been into edging his
wood I guess
all right would you like to Define it
for us for those who don't may not know
what it is who may yeah
um bringing yourself to the point you're
about to nut and then stopping and then
repeating that over and over again do
you get blue balls in that process yes
yes
yeah it just sounds painful yeah [ __ ]
that so is like are the blue balls a
part of the enjoyable experience for him
then I don't know I couldn't imagine
that I don't know why he would call him
up I've never truly had like painful
blue balls as I've heard it described I
feel like people over exaggerated to try
it maybe I'm just [ __ ] so much
have you ever purposely not jacked off
for a time period
uh
because I was at work or something
[Laughter]
about four to six hours without it I've
definitely gotten time periods undefined
uh length for without I read something
called sexual transmutation it's
supposed to like better your life if
you're a guy especially right with your
career goals and everything else in your
life so I read it it was like powerful
just they said like you just can't jack
off or if you jack off don't come so I
tried that I did it for like a month
which is crazy a month and I've never
had a wet dream in my life ever right
yeah of course I had a wet dream after
during that period because like I just
couldn't let it go yeah that's that was
my blue balls yeah maybe I should try
that and get my life together no but I
don't think it worked it was just like
[ __ ] it was just suffering but that's
huge and uh what's like um no fap no fap
is the whole movie purpose of that
though it's no jerking off and it's
supposed to like make you more alert no
not November yeah no not November's a
thing but no fap's just like a way of
life it's like oh
okay so they think it just makes you
more more alert more focused yeah just
better at what you do
is it I also think women can smell the
pheromones if you have like [ __ ] coming
out your [ __ ] years I'm not I swear
to God I swear to God
like such a nice smell to them and I
don't know maybe it does have to do with
if you're not fapping you just have more
like pheromones you can just like I
probably smell it
I'm working over it ever since I got
dubbed I just want to bless you Kyle I'm
working that yeah
hold open
how do you do that exact thing he tried
to it wasn't necessarily to get his life
together he just wanted to challenge
himself and he's like I'm gonna go a
month without jacking off I was like
okay cool by week two he was so [ __ ]
irritable and angry at the world then he
just decided to jack off that night the
next day in school he's like I feel so
much better oh my God I feel that again
you didn't make it to your goal so that
kind of sucks too but of course you're
gonna feel better he said he thought it
was stupid that he even tried because it
didn't have a good effect on him the
whole two weeks he was just angry at
everyone that's that's what Theo does
all the time
that's why he's so angry then it makes
perfect sense and you get so much
hornier if you don't do it for like that
long
you look at every situation
what's the longest he gone without
jerking off I don't I don't know today
how many days I feel like yeah I don't
know I told you when I did it on purpose
for like a month
probably probably two or three days
maybe that's fair George
hey man I'm just trying my best out here
George is Young he doesn't I feel like
I've gone maybe like a few months before
but the moment I can't sleep I need to
rub one out because it'll help me go to
bed yeah that's the only way I won't
think of it unless I have insomnia and
Stevie always makes fun of me and he's
very upset by this info because he
didn't know like that's just what I do
so if he's on the road and I can't sleep
now he just knows I'm like ferociously
masturbating trying to go through that
ferociously yes ferocious
I just want to go to bed he secretly uh
drugging you with caffeine right because
you're just so you're just up all night
ravaging yourself no he's the type I'm
uncomfortable he's like stop he's like
leave me alone okay uh I've never really
taken oh we talked about that one time
uh I've never really taken NyQuil I took
Tylenol PM one time and it knocked me
out for [ __ ] 12 hours I was like try
a NyQuil shrooms it might be the same
ingredient though that diphen diphenyl
something whatever that's the sleeping
ingredient I think they put it in
Tylenol Tylenol ibuprofen like Advil PM
Tylenol PM and maybe NyQuil I'm not sure
though I'm not sure if the nofap thing
will help you like
increase Focus whatever but I know
something that will what Magic Mike
this stuff damn right I don't magic of
mine yeah
yes thank you
speaking of Fab no we're fapping now
are you done
so for the those of you that are just
joining us uh because you refuse to
watch the show when Chappelle was on uh
I don't think that's anyone I know there
was a boycott
uh magicmine.com
use promo code dark so you can get 20
off magic mind this once daily shot this
Elixir it's the anti-procrastination
drink it'll give you more Focus it's got
30 milligrams of caffeine and 12 other
natural ingredients that'll help you
focus throughout your day uh I know
Kyle's been taking it and it's literally
how he got this job he took it before he
even got here and that's not a lie
cheers the only reason I came on this
show
foreign
[Music]
for real if anybody has bought magic
mind at magicbine.com promo code dark
email your receipt to King uh
catsaverdark gmail.com and we'll Zoom
you in and we want to hear your
testimonial about how it's changed your
life
I like it that we already got the uh the
renew when we had James bashara on the
show
he's amazing he's great he's great more
entertaining than Christians do you
think he
Christian's dad is really entertaining
like once we got past the the sales
pitch like he was super funny and [ __ ]
he wanted to get he wanted to get stuff
out there uh uh I hope he's not mad at
me for covering up with Chappelle's
tumbling footage he did he said next
time he sees you it's on site oh well
then he can't come on the show again
but um no he he was kind of upset that
because he wanted to come in tomorrow
and he's like see how it was all done
and then I told him that we weren't
doing it anymore and I think he was a
little upset about it he was sad he
couldn't why couldn't he come today
um because my dad my dad when he was in
town he rented a Ferrari and he wanted
to pull up in a Ferrari and now he
doesn't have the car so he's like I want
to go that's my dad in a nutshell that's
super funny but I was
um
Chappelle's fault because we were gonna
do it yesterday your dad was gonna come
with pharah he had a Rari yesterday and
he yeah I didn't I missed it you put it
on your social I think or oh you
probably shouldn't have that up we
should definitely just text messages
probably some dick pics we don't know
good for you
yeah definitely don't want that getting
out well actually I do
why not spell texted me very nice not
mad at him anymore I hear you do work
for yourself I do individually uh I
individually texted him uh and he said
completely understand your frustration
uh what happened again brother I'm gonna
cut this out but uh
I love Chappelle me too the best
I like I wasn't even really mad I was
just starting to get worried he didn't
want to be on the show anymore yeah
I think he's good he thought he was
gonna break up with us uh yeah a little
bit
yeah it's just heartbreak season I want
to name the episode Chappelle quits last
week just to like stoke the fire yeah
but I asked him first and he was like
no uh Johnny puts in a picture on his
actual wall yeah but I wanted to find
the one oh yeah with your dad yeah
but this is a Ferrari but that's a
Ferrari my dad was driving
and this is his mother's day
appreciation post
that's hilarious that is really [ __ ]
funny
God bless your mother I've seen a lot of
people do that too yeah they'll take
pictures of the mom but you can see half
the mom's face a bunch of those uh Blake
Lively and Ryan Reynolds did that a lot
back and forth because Ryan Reynolds
used to post [ __ ] like oh happy birthday
to the love of my life and be a picture
of him and then like half of it Blake
and she would do the same thing to him
except for the main photo would be Ryan
Gosling and then half of her husband
they're they're a great couple they're
great I love them uh at uh Jimmy Kimmel
did it to um
Adam carollo one time like way back in
the day he like he took out an ad in LA
Times he's like wished him a happy
birthday and cut off half his face
classic maneuver I one time at the Adam
Carolla show when I worked there Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar was the guest and it was
super excited like Mo like
you guys probably feel this like when
you start everybody who comes in is
[ __ ] dope like I got yeah I asked
[ __ ] Michelle Beadle for a picture
and but then it kind of wears off and
you're like you're like less excited to
see people but Kareem Abdul-Jabbar came
in was super excited I I like went up it
was like I would do like Hospitality
with the gas I was like oh you you need
anything he's like oh you guys got any
orange juice and I was like oh let me
check we didn't have any orange juice so
I took ab's car I went to the gas
station I got every type of orange juice
they got I brought it back to him hand
it to him I was like which one you want
it was pretty funny moment on the way
out I asked him uh if I could get a
picture with him and he he was like no
and he pulled out a stack of cards in
his pocket that were autographed and he
handed me that's even better it's not
him did he say why uh he just
he's really
if you hear him with interviews he's
like kind of a crotchety old man uh and
like he just didn't like this has been
his ammo there's a show on HBO right now
about the Lakers in the 1970s Bo Burnham
plays uh Larry Bird I'm pretty sure in
it which is crazy yeah
um and uh John C Riley's in it uh and I
guess Will Ferrell's like pissed to Adam
McKay because he didn't get cast in it
dissolve their company production
company dope I [ __ ] hate anime
I got laid off from funny though right
yeah uh but um
so in that movie there's a scene where
Kareem tells a this is like late 70s he
tells some kid to [ __ ] off who asked him
for a autograph so it's evidently like a
thing and my buddy Dylan who I do that
podcast with he has a story he was at
some like black dinner when he was like
eight his like his mom is like some
producer or something but he went up to
Kareem there and he was like eight years
old and Kareem turned him down so it's
like [ __ ] on an eight-year-old yeah
so I [ __ ] hate Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
not a father not a fan I thought it was
one of those things you could clip that
and send it to him anybody yes you could
clip it
I'll find definitely I'll get it I'm
saying any friends of him or Kareem if
you see it did you hear about the Stefan
Bonner Patty Pembroke thing no I'm
intrigued you guys know Patty pembly he
was on a food truck batteries recently
Patty the Baddie Patty the Baddie so he
during like the UFC 274 or some Press
Conference during that time they're
asking questions about like an incident
that happened so when he was around
Twitter thing no no oh no no so when he
was around 12 years old
uh I guess UFC was in Europe for some
reason for like you know a show
something like that and then he saw
Stephen Bonner and he walked out to him
he's like can I get a picture with you
and Steph bar is like I don't have time
he just walked away he's never forgotten
it and it's changed the way he does
because he's like he's super huge right
now so he he says he's still upset with
Stefan Bonner and he doesn't treat fans
that way at all so he always takes
pictures of fans he didn't burn down
Stefan Bonner's house did he no dude
that would make sense that would make
sense dude donated two grand to that
cause on air uh yes stuff and botters
yeah uh that wasn't a random joke Stefan
Bonner's house
I'm connected right there
oh that's not bad and then have the meme
of that little girl in front of the
burning school oh I had already decided
uh that this one's gonna be called cat
quits cat quit Okay because last week I
want to do Chappelle Quest and then next
week is addressing the controversy
if you guys ever seen Logan Paul's go to
Logan Paul the impulsive YouTube page
and just look at the titles
he is perfected YouTube like if you want
a successful YouTube channel just take
his template and do what he does Paul
and Mr Beast yes
oh my God
it gave me motivation to just move out
here his brain works too
and he's so young he's like 23 or
something like yeah it's crazy
and like yeah his goal is like oh he
says my goal is to change the world and
he's literally going to like he's just
amassing this Army of people we're gonna
I don't know
their impulsive Instagram is is very
smart as well with how they do their
stories what are the titles of some of
the shows can you
Joe Rogan
I mean that's a great title right there
liver King calls out Joe Rogan oh yeah
discovering garyvee on discovering Logan
Paul
are you sad Christian no why you seem
sad no okay
maybe it's just sitting over here I
don't know that looks like there's a
sadness in your voice yeah
um
I'm just tired
um let's see yeah he's good they're
they're clickbaity but they still kind
of hooked up with our fan that's a good
one where I was at that well I was at
the place where Theo Von met that fan it
was uh it was Logan Paul's 100th episode
they had at his house I remember them
telling that story and uh Theo went on
it me Gianni were you there that day
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] oh yeah tank was there
too yeah that Machine Gun Kelly
performed in Logan's garage I was
actually with Theo uh at this episode
and he proceeded to tell everyone that I
was raised in the deli
that's a great origin story though Theo
is I I love this best weekend can you
sing obviously but he is so funny on
other people's shows I think I think all
the responsibilities off of it yeah yeah
he himself and not worry about any
production how the cameras work and he
responds to people asking him questions
so that like he works so quick like it's
gonna be funny Ryan is insane dude he's
looking around like new people new ideas
to play off of I think he gets bored
with like the regular like that's what
he gets stressed out about doing the
same episode over and over and over he
needs a lot of stimulus he's like a
German Shepherd like you need to keep
him exercise yeah plus he'll go crazy
should we get some [ __ ] sheep here
maybe you think he'll hurt him
[Music]
no that's Amber turd oh
yes yeah what are your thoughts any new
Revelations from this uh the seems like
that news has kind of died down it's
definitely died down I just find it so
interesting that people are coming out
of the Woodworks to support Johnny Depp
like the Makeup Company who outed Amber
Heard because her lawyer came out and
said she's actually a master at doing
cover-up and color correction she had
this little like color correcting makeup
set in her bag at all times during their
relationship to cover up bruises and
that's why nobody has recognized her
with these bruises and why so many
people are astounded to find out that
she is a victim of domestic abuse the
company that actually made that compact
came out shortly after that trial went
live online said this actually isn't
true because her relationship with
Johnny Depp happened from 2012 to 2016.
the compact that they're lifting up she
was made in 2017. so a Makeup Company
went out of their way to make a tick
tock thing she's [ __ ] lying and that
Tick Tock is probably
is that was that company already massive
I seemed like a pretty big company I
don't know how big it's not like a I
don't think it's a drug store like big
enough to be in a drugstore but maybe
yeah
tick tock's so crazy it just like I
don't know people just talk about how
there's like more kind of viewers than
there are people putting content on
there which seems insane to me because
it seems like everybody's making tick
tocks but like if you make tick tocks
they will come like it's weird we got we
need cats after dark Tick Tock I know uh
put real put reels on there yeah and I
don't know if that's different but no
it's it's basically the exact same thing
we need to do more clips of this the
only thing I want to avoid that's why I
haven't been like oh here's time quotes
have you guys cut it it's because like I
want the original footage always so it's
like cutting instead of like from the
final file but uh we're gonna we're
gonna get a pop and this Show's gonna be
huge yeah we're gonna be Mr Beast change
the world cats after dark yeah yeah
nobody's on Tick Tock do you have a tick
tock are you doing numbies I have a
chicken I really I'm one of those people
who love to consume tick tocks I don't
really go out of my way to make them
they're always an afterthought after I
do something I think back like oh I
could have made something out of this
but I'm not I just love being on Tick
Tock and finding the algorithm yeah
because based on my algorithm they I am
a bi woman with autism and ADHD
like that that that's my algorithm
verbatim like so am I though
I feel like George and I are kindred
spirit that's really what it is I
haven't used
she's talking enough but I know people
like the algorithm is good if he's huh
you haven't used it a lot really yeah I
feel like you would be on Tick Tock a
lot I'm I'm a creature of habit of uh
I'm on my Instagrams and my my Twitter
I'm on Twitter a lot I love Twitter
trippy interesting never on Twitter yeah
I love Twitter really yeah Twitter seems
like your app yeah I like seeing I like
seeing the things that Trend and then
like finding out why they're trending
and then I feel like I learned about
it's I and I feel like they've gotten a
little bit away from it it used to be
all like
crazy alt left [ __ ] like really far left
[ __ ] that like oh they're really mad
that this they culture appropriated
braids yeah uh but it's like a lot less
of that now now with there being so many
more social media platforms now is it
easier to get in touch with people on
Twitter and get a response back from you
know people that you admire or you know
that you'd want to work with I think I
think it's depending on the person like
some people have their DMS open they're
like I I use this and I interact with
people like but yes I think like my
Twitter DMs well I'll go months without
seeing them but I always check Instagram
yeah I don't know because I mean I just
remember back in the day when Twitter
like if you got a response from someone
with verified you're like oh I made it
like I'm gonna be Twitter famous and I
just didn't know if it was still like
that nothing nothing really entertaining
trending
no
so what's everybody got going on that
they want to check out
the plugs our plugs I'll start uh
I know with my new channel coming up two
people that helped me a lot with my uh
logos and pictures were uh Reuben and
Jenna Sunday oh nice oh they're great so
I wanted to give a special shout out to
them too because I love them and
uh how did you get in touch with Jenna
sun or like how does she know of you did
you get uh the first ever podcast that
put a clip on was bad friends yeah so I
got uh when Jenna worked for bad friends
she was very good at running the social
medias like on top of it and I was still
450 pounds I was the very start of my
weight loss journey and one of my
friends that also are a fan of bad
friends they uh
bought me this t-shirt for the podcast
merch but it was like one of the fake
ones because I was in a size 6X t-shirt
so I sent a little DM and I was like I
know it's fake I'm so sorry but like hey
I'm like you know I'm trying real hard
to lose weight freaking love you guys
yeah and then she took my little clip
and she dm'ed me back and she was like
hey uh follow me this is my this is me
the human behind the thing like just
like keep in touch with me and just
really became like a podcast big sister
to me oh that's sweet it's awesome yeah
oh yeah she worked on a whiskey Ginger
yeah yeah she does a lot of like uh uh
Chrissy D Santino Ari shaffir like
posters for their shows and stuff and
she has jokes and she does like she does
TV work like motion graphic work and
stuff I think that's why she left kind
of the podcast world to like go back to
that but like
view watch basically any of these shows
with these individual comedians as they
get bigger they start to get more
polished and she was the one that
polished whiskey Ginger and bad friends
like quite a bit like her work is
amazing yeah yeah beautiful stuff there
was like an arms race with like podcasts
for a while they just kept like stepping
up with like the production and just
looking pretty kind of level with like
production value because you can't
there's there's always yeah unless
you're like Rick Glassman who is his
podcast is amazing he does all these
effects and he's doing it all on his own
his show still you ever watch this uh
once or twice uh I seen Big B on there
with his big yellow suit on oh yeah they
wear hazmat suits it was like right at
the beginning of the pandemic uh good
[ __ ] good [ __ ] uh so what is the channel
is it live already uh my channel is
called go George go I haven't uploaded
yet because I'm still making the videos
getting close but uh maybe by the time
this is out it'll be done if I [ __ ]
kick my ass in gear and if and if you're
not done you should put like a YouTube
short being like yes this is my channel
even say your story in like one minute
yeah that'd be dope definitely Christian
what's up ah just Instagram see
Halo 6 thank you very gross
um Tick Tock christian.paolo and that's
about it and uh are you work are you
working on uh
uh I really love the name of Gianni show
what's it what's good podcast who has it
um yeah who has it that's that's so
Gianni I love it uh yeah uh once that
starts to kick off a little more I'm
gonna be doing uh social media for his
podcast I just started doing uh social
media for Keenan Thompson and his
production company and his podcast as
well so um once they get a couple more
episodes in I go back to Rhode Island
next week uh because my best friend uh
is getting married even though he cheats
on his girlfriend all the time hey man
you can't say that can you no yeah it's
a known thing okay yeah
that is insane that is wild it's kind of
she knows
I mean always know okay we always know
you want to hear Kind of a Funny Story
sure this is gonna be [ __ ] up kind of
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] her no
that'd be [ __ ] up [ __ ] her with
George's dick let me put it that way I
would think I can't believe you're going
to this wedding with the way you're
talking about these people but I hate
them
well I hate the girl but this kid I've
literally known since I've been in
diapers he's like one of my oldest
friends
um we've been trying to convince him to
break up with her for about a year and a
half
not at work because the only reason
you're gonna be they're gonna ask for
injections yeah
me and my boys
what's uh in Princess she's like witch
you think I'm [ __ ] up
me and all of our friends like everyone
in our friend group were planning on
bringing an ex-girlfriend each of us
were going to come to his wedding with
an ex-girlfriend of his as our dates and
then we all got Tyler Perry movie yeah
we all got our plus ones revoked but um
yeah mainly mainly on her part he
thought it was [ __ ] hysterical but
she was not a fan
um this is funny it sounds like some
sitcom type situation but it's really
sad actually their wedding yeah Jesus
Christ
admission when we when the light turned
off their camera wasn't recording the
whole time oh so George we only but we
saw your story I thought you were just
disappointed I couldn't get the light
back and I was like
part of the reason I want to say it you
didn't do anything wrong I did uh joke
tell us about the sweater so two things
one basically this is the reason why we
all hate her we were supposed to go out
uh he joined the Air Force because like
we were all moved away
to get out of Rhode Island and do
something and like I told him I was
trying to convince him to come to La she
convinced him to join the Air Force and
then he joined there for us and then she
said marry me and we won't have to live
you won't have to live on base where you
can live in a house with me so he's dumb
and he did that and continued to cheat
on her and the when we were supposed to
have a boys night she called every
single bar in Rhode Island and that we
were planning on going to and said that
we had coveted and not to let us in oh
my God so that and then uh she that's
pretty dope
I feel like if you cheat on me that's
the least I could do oh my God but the
one of the times she cheated on him and
she did it though no no no no no no oh
yeah this poor lady damn it yeah you
guys are mean
she can do better I think she needs no
she can't should we go to this wedding
yeah on her side yeah we object on her
behalf yes but this is this basically
sums up my friend she also may enjoy the
military I feel like that's a little
manipulative she can't [ __ ] other girls
in the military oh no he did I mean he
did he cheated on her that's how we
cheated on her he cheated on her at boot
camp and then his like first week
knocking boot camp
um
so his first week back she found out
that she cheated on him uh he cheated on
her at our boys graduation party and the
entire ride back because they driven me
they drove me and it was very awkward I
was in the back seat she was driving
bong her eyes out and he was just
sitting in the passenger seat laughing
um and because mainly because she was
playing uh not Mariah Carey's who Carrie
Underwood's before I cheat I'm not
kidding she was playing it on repeat
bawling her eyes out singing the song
and like slapping him while she was
driving and then I just got a text he's
like jam out to the song so she gets mad
it's not that sad that's not that funny
of a story I guess I just thought it's
really weird yeah yeah and it's dark I
don't like this guy I don't like any of
them yeah I don't think I would go to
this wedding I kind of have to yeah
mainly because I feel like it's the last
time I'll ever see the kid again after
they officially get married when when do
you when is this the 19th through the
23rd so you'll be here for next week's
recording yeah is there any way we could
zoom this guy in yes yes yes we'll just
tell them what's up I just quit doing
what you're doing no no no no no no no
if we Zoom him in the the only way I
will have him zoom in is if we can come
up with a way to get them to break up
well I mean we're going to have him zoom
in and we'll just yeah we'll talk we're
gonna be there we're gonna be therapists
it's gonna be a six-on-one therapy
session hear more about um
what he's done because I'm not swayed
right now like I'm not on his side if he
calls in here yeah you will trust me yes
I did I gave you a very brief brief okay
explanation of it because I didn't know
we're going over and out
you tell me it was it was funny but yeah
yeah we'll see she's uh yeah I just
don't believe in cheating
I do so that's Christian's plug or Rhode
Island weddings
uh check out another podcast show doing
some really fun stuff on there waste
wasting people's time we like to call up
customer service people extend those
type of interactions uh food reviewers
uh we never watched report of the week
maybe we'll go all right we'll do next
week yeah yeah next week
um cat what do you got Instagram is teen
and onlyfans.com teen that's it Kyle oh
yeah
um real quick so one more time uh this
Tuesday upcoming Tuesday May 17th it's
me little Bros Chappelle AC has been mad
peaceful and some other guests and
everyone here is going to be there as
well so we it would mean the world to me
if you guys all showed up and just had
fun with us talk to us do whatever you
guys want enjoy
um and other than that I haven't really
uploaded YouTube stuff for a little
while but if you do want to check it out
it's chinsu Yi and my Instagram is
chinsuki
and uh a couple of people that have said
they're going to be at the show but
they're not on the poster didn't Chris
say he's gonna be there Christy Lee said
he's gonna try to stop by if he's in
town Eric Griffin but again not on the
post yeah so no refunds I'm not saying
for sure what's happening yeah Eric
Griffin Brian Cowan said he's going to
be there for sure we have over under on
that yeah we don't know he's gonna do
two Tough Mudders yeah so we'll see what
happens but it's gonna be a fun time
can't wait to meet everyone so yeah
please come out
um I don't really have anything to plug
right now uh Instagram's Kyle Varney
with a v-a-r-n-e-y underscore
um yeah just go like my pictures you
know send me DMS if you're you know if
you're a single mom in the LA area uh I
know fat Sal's um they got some good
buffalo chicken stuff there chin
wouldn't like it but uh yeah that's
really all I got
I spent thousands of dollars on fats
it's so good I was blown away there was
a year of my life I'd get high and I
just ordered two sandwiches two of them
pushing it but every time you're there I
like that I like that I like the fat
sales gravy turkey fry or gravy fries
Turkey
um I mean God I'd have to
the fat Jaime is guacamole Buffalo huh
the fat Jerry's like that that's like
the uh the staple uh the steak fries
ketchup yup yeah
you could quiz me on this menu I I it's
it's just names and it's awesome have
you had the buffalo chicken one oh yeah
yeah uh fat Buffalo
it's great what are their least creative
names if you ever there's a
contest there where if you I can't
remember what the sandwich is but it's
insane it's like 30 inches or something
but if you finish it you can create your
own sandwich it could be the fat you can
name it whatever you want it could be
the fat dick I've thought about calling
it The Fat Packer and having cheese
curds on it uh but maybe that's what you
could do in here I don't know if I could
finish it though but with some magic
mine and a little bit of Kratom I think
anything's possible
yeah anything's possible I forgot to say
it's at the Troubadour so if you want to
buy tickets just go to the Troubadour
website or just go to my Instagram it's
in the bio you should buy a little
browser what Kratom do you use so dude
this is a question I get so much like
what strains and everything I've tried
all different brands and I don't notice
I really don't notice the difference but
then I usually do red strain and then
white strain Red's more relaxing White's
supposed to make you a little bit more
alert because we have to reach out to
them uh like the ones you use and try to
get spots one of the uh sponsors that
sponsors the show had a real long talk
on he's like the CEO so he knows me very
well I know him very well so I can reach
out to him but I want to be able to say
how like you shouldn't take it daily if
we do get a sponsor of it because I
think it's like bad for people but like
I mean like it could be anything all
things in moderation don't don't rely on
it yeah so if it's something that adds
to your life sure if it's something that
you doesn't I never promote it like you
should do it I'm always like do your
research try it if you know if you think
after your research that it's okay then
it's up to you you're you know you're an
adult I never say like you should do it
I'm just like this is what I do you do
it daily right daily I think that's why
your masturbation thing didn't work out
you were focusing with Kratom and trying
to focus from not coming I hear your
Kyle and they were [ __ ] head button
each other I hear you but I did I did
create them way later in my life I'm
just saying I just thought in my head
that's probably why your your [ __ ] cycle
didn't work out because I can't remember
if I said this on air but like when I
was in Denver a couple weeks ago when
you told me oh yeah I don't think I said
an air went to okay a year ago when I
went to Denver it was with my grandma
and my sister uh and Jules and we went
to a kava bar which is like another
natural ingredient type thing but they
also sold Kratom drinks there and we got
Kratom drinks and like it was me my 84
year old grandma my sister and my
girlfriend and we're all like wow you're
[ __ ] really relaxed right now and
then and then we went back to Denver
this year her sister my grandma's sister
is in Denver and she's Alzheimer's so we
brought her a visit and we're like let's
go to that kava bar again we went again
and it was it's like [ __ ] it's a fun
little cafe type experience but don't
take it every day it's addicting yeah
like I said just do your research
cool
should we bring someone else in to plug
something is there anyone plugged yeah I
think everybody's plugged everyone's
plugged that sounds plugged in by the
way that's it all right yeah thanks for
watching Chappelle should be here next
week he said he'll be back next week all
right feel better Chappelle whatever's
going on if Nick's hostile takeover does
not work Chappelle will be back if he's
not back
you know what happened he bought a lot
of revolution
I need one it's bad
but yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna put a mask
on it and like make me Tanner and not
make you Tanner let's go get spray tans
together all the time it works just do
it you do spray tan all the time I just
need to go outside the bottles
I just need to go outside I want to
start playing basketball outside
do we need a cat's pickup game we do
browse plays I know browse is a lot
better Justin
we talked about it uh playing ball uh
yeah we should we should get that
popping
it's really hard to find the level of
game I want I don't want to play with
people who are too bad I don't want to
play with people or do good it works
I've been shooting at LA Fitness with
some of the inner city kids uh it's like
the Woodland Hills OH Irish they're all
rich I played uh pills in our city yeah
I played at the LA uh LA Fitness in
Glendale lots of really hardcore
Filipino Ballers there yeah oh yeah
Filipinos know how to get down oh yeah
they're they're five six scary 50 Manny
Pacquiao playing basketball
it's like he's he's really good yeah
yeah yeah like he's a little compact
little man Pat or uh chin was the one I
don't know why I said Pat chin was the
one that said uh Filipinos are their
closest Asians two black people to like
the urban community yeah yeah
number two I would say cambodians
the cambodians I know and the Filipinos
I know I would say just the style the
way their Swagger and everything I think
the Filipinos are more close and plus
Filipinos can sing they can dance they
can do a lot of stuff are you
stereotyping black people I'm just
saying and then also Koreans can sing
they can dance and all that stuff I
can't dance but I'm saying like and also
I think uh
I feel like I've never really
I've interacted with a lot of people
from Korean community and Filipino
Community I don't think I've really ever
met anybody who's like I'm Cambodian oh
really yeah I swear to God oh really
yeah they happen to be a lot of gang
bangers Oh Long Beach but definitely in
Long Beach you don't know the names
We're not gonna see them
stop the grounds well that's it for cats
after dark that's it yeah if you're
Cambodian hit up uh Nick and say hi take
us home what you guys look like I don't
believe you exist Cambodian friends
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]